so if I were to ask you right now who
gets the best out of you who in your
life gets the best at you meaning a
coach a mentor or boss a father and
Uncle a brother a sister somebody that
gets the best out of you would probably
come up with a couple names right but
what if I ask you who in your life gets
the worst out of you somehow someway it
agitates you they get under your skin
they make you feel insecure bad not good
and it doesn't make you perform I'm not
talking about a guy that drives you I'm
talking about a downer do you have
people like that in your life you can
probably think about somebody in your
life so here's a question what's more
important is it more important to
surround yourself about around a bunch
of these guys that are the winners who
get the best out of you or is it more
important to try to just avoid at all
costs people who tend to get the worst
out of you Russell Wilson was a Super
Bowl champion got a hold of this one guy
who was Premier at developing a Winner's
mindset his name is Trevor my one when
he got a hold of Russell Wilson in 2012
they talked every single day on the
phone until he died in 2021. I'm going
to share with you five techniques he
used to to get people mentally strong
that'll give you some insight into it if
you get valued from the video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it so I want to
give a quick shout out to our sponsor
this video better help better help is
the world's largest therapy service and
it's online 25 000 therapists it's an
important thing here to tell you a story
about what happened to me years ago 20
years ago I'm an entrepreneur I'm in LA
and I'm talking to my business
colleagues who are bigger than me and I
said hey is there somebody I can go talk
to they said there's this therapist in
Santa Monica I would drive an hour away
because this guy would work with c-suite
Executives and Founders to go sit with
this guy one it wasn't discreet there
was other people in there two at a two
hour drive in LA traffic couldn't stand
it and three I didn't have a lot of
other people that specialized
specifically in business this was my
only guy I wish there was a platform
that had more options that was online
that was discreet and you do now it's
called better help so to take advantage
of better Hub you can simply go to
betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment once again betterhelp.com
you get 10 discount for the first month
of service you use with them Russell
Wilson goes into the NFL I think his
draft was 2012. this guy's got a
reputation with Nick Saban he's worked
with over a dozen uh first round draft
picks 700 athletes coaches start
believing in this Trevor guys mindset of
developing leaders when him and Russell
Wilson met for the first time Russell
Wilson said hey man you know it's good
to meet you he says I hear you're
supposed to be great and he says what
are you supposed to be great at he says
in developing a Winner's mindset so what
is a Winner's mindset he had five
techniques used here's the first one go
neutral he says neutral thinking means
accepting the idea that when something
good or bad happens it just happens
instead of getting caught up in the
negativity of a bad path or a mental or
physical mistake you just accept that it
happened and move on meaning a lot of
times when you're doing things if you're
trying to do something big you're going
to make mistakes or you're gonna be
winning or you're going to be losing
you're gonna feel like oh my God I
shouldn't have done this I shouldn't
done that so that's his first technique
here's the second technique stop giving
credence to feelings feelings are
confusing and misleading sometimes they
are accurate depictions of reality and
sometimes they're not the more we pay
attention to our feelings the more we
move away from our capabilities and our
training so that's why I say don't pay
too much attention to your feelings
interesting feelings they come they go
don't give a lot of credence here's
technique number three use what you have
Russell recognized that he did not meet
the very specific rigorous standards
predetermined by the NFL relative to
height and other evaluations instead he
combine his behavior along with his
aptitude for football and said I'm going
to use what I have rather than let the
outside world tell me what I don't have
again remember people that get the best
out of you people that get the worst out
of you people that get the best out of
you typically work with what you have
people that get the worst out of you
typically will compare you to other
people on what they have and what you
don't have why you can't be as good as
them and somehow some way they get the
worst out of you not effective technique
number four focus on reducing negativity
not increasing positivity less negative
is significantly more powerful than more
positive look what he says less negative
is more powerful the more positive
having fewer people in your life that
get the worst out of you is more
effective than having more people in
your life that get the best out of you
what that's exactly how this thing works
going back to how we started let me just
give you the last technique and I'll
give you some thoughts here's this fifth
technique watch your language what you
say out loud is far more powerful than
your self-talk great teams are great at
communicating powerfully and positively
with each other it matters less what you
tell yourself and more what you tell
your teammates you really got to watch
your external language if you're going
to succeed and so look pick and choose
whichever the five techniques apply to
you but for me the biggest one is I was
watching a video the other day of game
Dash and he just opens it up he says I
hate negative people he says if the
first thing I come up with while I'm
thinking about ideas is your negative
ideas why you don't think it could work
out I don't need you in my life there's
a time and place to talk about the
problems but when I'm Dreaming don't be
negative so again go back to the first
question I asked you who gets the worst
out of you you know what the problem
with this whole concept is let me tell
you why this thing sucks you ready you
know why this thing sucks when I ask you
who gets the worst out of you you know
sometimes why this suck because
sometimes that person is blood and you
love them it's hard your dad it's your
mom it's your brother it's your sister
it's your cousin your grandpa your
grandma you're like dude I love you but
what the hell is the matter with you and
you get the worst out of people the way
you do it is so difficult to do what I'm
about to tell you to do and most people
will not do it you know how you go on a
diet to not eat sweets I'm not gonna eat
sweets for the next 30 days I'm not
gonna eat any starch or I'm gonna go do
this I'm gonna do that for six months
I'm not I haven't had any soda since
July of 2019 I believe okay I don't know
how long that is that's a long time I
haven't had soda I used to drink three
Coke Zeros a day I haven't had any right
how long do you think you can go
avoiding
those people that get the worst out of
you you think you can go on a 30-day
diet what do you think
if you live with them you have a problem
foreign
if you live with them you got a problem
but man you got to do your best it's
like the ice cream is in the fridge and
somebody else eats it you have to avoid
that ice cream you gotta avoid the
people that get the worst out of you see
if you can do for 30 days see what
happens to you see if you can do for 60
90 days see what happens to you
life-changing I'm convinced as much as
somebody can lift you up and how
powerful these people are to say I
believe you can do it go get them I
believe as powerful as these guys are
the people that know how to pull you
down are a hundred times more powerful
in these gets I'm convinced because if
it wasn't the case more people would be
winning in life but they're not because
these guys are so freaking good at what
they do and they got you as well many
times now some of you are watching this
this one's gonna hurt so brace for
impact uh you're not gonna like this
part and then you're gonna give me a
thumbs down or whatever you're gonna do
it's all good I'm a big boy I can handle
it some of you guys are watching it's
like you know what it's my boss
it's that person it's this person all
the people that get the worst out of me
that's why I'm not winning no you maybe
that person for somebody else not saying
you are and he said how do I gauge this
very simple you ready how many people
around you the five people you hang out
with the most are winning in life
they're positive and they're happy if
they are and they're advancing and life
is getting better you're not that person
but if the fat people around you in your
life are all bitching complaining
struggling financially always blaming
somebody else you get to pick and choose
this was not a message for everybody but
either way whatever it is I was at
church this Sunday and the guy was given
a message it was a powerful message my
son decided to go to the big room with
me Tico was your Center sitting here and
we're sitting there listening to this
guy give this message powerful
um the great thing about life reason why
there's this word called Grace I was a
screw-up for a big chunk of my life I
chose to change at any point you and I
can change however some of you that are
watching this St Patrick the reason why
I'm still hanging around people that get
the worst out of me because I believe I
can change them what if I can change
them and they say you could change them
so God could change them if you think
you can change them you think your god
oh that's a big risk you're taking right
there I don't recommend it one of the
most powerful affirmations of my life at
26 years old I added you know what it
was stop trying to be God that job is
already taken and some of you may be
trying to be God you can't change those
people only they can change people only
life can change them only God can change
them and if you want to be God you can
spend 10 20 30 years wasting your life
thinking they're going to change and
they're going to suck you down to their
level heavy message congratulations it's
Monday this is when the video goes out
if it's the right message can change
your life for the right person watching
this you may even be emotional right now
in the car listening to this glute pull
over the car because you got some
thinking to do I understand how heavy
today's message could be because it was
very heavy for me 20 years ago 18 years
going out to make this Choice very very
hard very emotional very hard but I'm
thankful I did it and you will be as
well if you got value from this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel I got another video for you to
watch they deal with negative team
members if you've never seen it click
here to watch the video take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]